good morning John it's uh what is it oh
I remember what it is it's New York yeah
I'm serious I'm I'm totally in time
spare right I was just in the time
square was the square in fact Times
Square is a triangle I'm being
advertised to like I've never been
advertised to before in my life I am
totally gonna leave here and I'm gonna
buy so much stuff mostly I need to
coca-cola things right now oh my god
Hanks in New York and I'm not gonna get
to see him well it turns out that may
not actually be true so this is good
news yeah what a great backdrop for
video we're still gonna movie I have a
plan for nerdfighters who are in or
around New York City and that plan is to
hang out at Barnes and Nobles and Union
Square Union Square that's correct I
keep saying unique station which is
wrong that's a completely different City
the Barnes and Noble and Union Square is
where I will be tomorrow at the six
o'clock so what do you think of that you
think you could be there you know if
you're like in Florida I excuse me for
not coming but anywhere else in the East
Coast you have to be here okay but it
again do it do it be there he's gonna be
me and a special guest who you may
already have guests
Wow guests and guests are the same word
guests and
so spelled if we would have said the
same anyway special guest Maureen
Johnson will be there signing any books
you would like to buy of hers from that
Barnes & Noble will be hopefully
upstairs in the conference room I
actually hear it's quite a big
conference room so it should get us all
I won't have my guitar with me so I'm
visa gonna be songs but I will be
hanging out and if you want to buy some
of John's books I'll sign them for you
I'm not John but you know they're people
waving to me
Everson wanted me in my video and I
don't know why but that's New York if
there's any place in the world where you
can put a camera yourself and talk like
a stupid person is right here this is
the place that's the whole job of this
place is to attract weird people to it
so the reason we're having this part
Sanibel event is because apparently the
Barnes & Noble in Manhattan doesn't
think that John Green can draw a crowd
so the plan is to have a little bit of
an unsanctioned event unsanctioned
unplanned spur-of-the-moment where
everyone can get together and show
Barnes Innova that yes nerdfighters can
indeed create a crowd so if you would
like to contribute that effort I would
like to see you at the Barnes & Noble in
Union Square at six o'clock tomorrow
what's tomorrow
I don't know today is I have no idea
it's tomorrow August 6 so yes this is a
good place to film the video I feel like
I should do like 12 here so that I can
just keep having Time Square videos but
you know I've got plans we're going to
Chicago and that's gonna be a whole
different ballgame so this is the only
New York video you're gonna get done
I'll see you in like three days
nerdfighters